my ability to fool other people
because it's a game right you're playing
a game and
everyone's trying to be someone and the
better you can pretend to be someone is
as good as it'll ever look to someone
else I don't know who I am at the end of
it
which is interesting because I don't
know you know like there's a you expect
to be a certain kind of person you think
you're a certain kind of person and when
you don't know
then you're confused and you're blessing
yourself
um I'm a drug addict like straight up
like I'm I'm sober now but I've been
I've struggled with drugs in the past
and I um you know like I work on it but
it's something that really scares me
about myself because I know how
self-destructive I can be and I know
that like if I don't keep on working on
this problem I have then eventually I
will just like self-destruct and
possibly kill myself
my anger
anger scares me can you give us an
example of a time where your anger
scared you yeah like I told my boyfriend
on my boyfriend was cheating on me and I
was afraid I might kill the girl you
were what I was afraid of my killer
not like murder
that scared me
oh the thing that scares me about myself
is how
easily and fast I get attached to
things and ideas of things and ideas of
people slash people let's say
let's say you start talking to somebody
as soon as you start talking to somebody
and they give you the most little bit of
attention boom I'm attached come here
let's talk more let's hang out like
literally
um same with friends too like the second
I meet somebody if we match energies
boom
where we're connected we're you're now
part of me kind of situation
it happens to you defines you as a
person and I forget that
I'm one thousand percent judged on what
I've done in the past and my wrong
dealings my shortcomings so I would say
being defined by
the things that make me vulnerable yeah
is this something you think about often
oh uh probably every day yeah I think I
struggle with opening up yeah
my future
that's what I would say I don't have any
like future plans I don't really know
myself too well so I don't really have
anything to look forward to I guess
what scares me the most about myself is
that I can do anything that I want like
I'm the luckiest person alive I think
um I would love to do a lot of simple
things and I'd like to do a lot of
complicated things I would love to be a
chemist I'd love to be an environmental
engineer I love to learn about algae and
oysters I love to be a leaf I'd like to
be a tree I'd like to be an elephant
anyway yeah so the fact that
you could in your in your mind you could
be any of these things and you can't
decide that's what scares you most
yeah
yeah I'm scared to decide
um I find it really hard to focus
probably like every three months I shift
gears and on this is my thing now and
then
it lasts three months right now it's
sailing failing sailing I yeah I just
bought a boat in Mexico for not enough
money it's a really shitty boat how long
ago did you get into Philly about three
months ago
you have me thinking though like why why
do we feel like we have to stick with
one thing our whole life like why not do
what you do because I'm a really shitty
saver and I'm not a particularly good
anything else either
but I know a little bit about a lot of
it's not very useful to anybody though
okay
I'm scared that deep down I think
that I know I won't do what I want to do
with my life
and I think that's what scares me most I
don't know maybe I've Been Told that
by a lot of people
that I won't make it and that I'm not
good enough
[Music]
I'm not scared anymore I used to be
scared but I'm not scared anymore that's
that's my answer
um I think I have trouble
figuring out when to be guilty and when
not to be and when it should make sense
and when it shouldn't I often get a lot
of guilt put on me and I handle it
weirdly I just feel like I'm blamed for
stuff more than I should sometimes and
so
um I don't know if I need to work on
myself or if I shouldn't take the blame
as much I guess I feel like I'm stressed
out all the time
and like my brain kind of goes at like a
million miles a minute and like I can
never really turn it off and I think
that I worry that I'll never like
know like a full piece with myself and
like be able to just sit down with
myself and like
feel good being silent and like alone
and like not feel the need to be doing a
million things at once or like anxious
about everything
have you ever felt peace
I don't know
as much as we want to believe that we
know ourselves more than anybody else
there is
so much unpredictability infinitely
actually we are not the same person two
seconds ago that we are two seconds
later without her permission and I think
that's what scares me
um I
I feel like every day I'm a different
person and every day I have a different
set of morals and things that I know
aren't true about myself
but the next day
I'll think about the decisions I'll made
the previous I've made the previous day
and I'll realize that that's not who I
am
but I really don't know if it is who I
am or if it isn't because I think like
when I'm doing something
I'm doing it mostly just
based on like
what feels right because I've been told
that that's like the way to live but
what feels right is not always good for
everyone
and
I think what I'm most scared about
myself is
[Music]
how I harm people without knowing
and how that affects not just them but
another person that they know and
another person that they know and
ultimately like the world
and just not realizing
the weight of my actions
even the smallest actions and I guess
overall not having self-control
yeah that is really it's really scary
and it's really hard and
I don't really have anything that I feel
like I'm loyal to like I don't have
a set of morals that I'm loyal to and
because I like grew up like atheist and
so I I know most people like
it's just a part of their existence to
have like certain beliefs and for me
it's very ambiguous and like there are
many possibilities
and
I think that's why it's so hard for me
to Center myself and really see what is
true to me and what isn't and so I think
the only way that I can learn is through
experience
and a lot of mistakes and a lot of
damage which I don't want to do but
I have no other way of learning so
yeah
when I know that I want something and I
don't just do everything for it
why is that your answer is something
you've been thinking about a lot
um I
recently like met a stranger who gave me
you know your passion go for it and if
you don't go for it you're gonna regret
it for the rest of your life and I
literally have just had just decided I'm
gonna give up on it and
oh the potential to not Chase what I
know that I want is really scary where'd
you meet the stranger
um I was on a flight
um and I got moved actually to randomly
sit next to him and it was just an old
guy and he just started talking and it
was just divine intervention
I'm an artist
um and I want to be a musician and I had
just like I'm a sociology major and I
just decided to like hunker down and
just like give up and stop like doing
the thing that I love and the thing that
I wake up and think about every second
of my life and then I was talking to him
and he was like
why would you not yeah why would you not
because
I'm never gonna be the best in the room
but I'm also never gonna be with the
worst in the room and
I let myself like be scared of people
who are better than me rather than be
inspired by people who are better than
me and
I don't know it's just something I need
to stop doing and I just need to focus
on
doing the thing where can we find your
music
oh my eyes nowhere I
my bedroom sorry
hi everyone
um I have an exciting announcement I'm
working on a book of secrets so if you
have a secret that you would be okay
with me including in the book please
submit it by going to the link in my
description or by going to thrive.com
and hitting the leave a secret tab I
have it set up to where you will be
submitting the secret completely
anonymously please only share a secret
if you are 100 okay with me sharing it
in the book and all my other platforms
I'm hoping you'll be able to pre-order
the book by mid-november and that I'll
have them shipped out in time for the
holidays so keep an eye out for that
I'll let you guys know once it's ready
either on here or on one of my other
platforms and
um that's about it thank you guys for
everything I love you all and I'll see
you next week
[Music]
foreign